President Obama says that it's time for
women to hold more power
watch out of this political darkness I
am seeing a Great Awakening it is a
movement of citizens who happened to be
younger and more diverse and more female
than ever before and that's really
useful we need more women in charge he
could have done his part by the way I
think I mean I gotta check my notes but
I think he ran against a woman a woman
who came closer than any other woman in
American history to becoming president
but he sabotage her campaign in part by
calling her does it sound familiar a
racist
her name was Hillary Clinton dan bond
Gina was a former Secret Service agent
and the author of the book spy gate the
attempted sabotage of Donald J Trump and
he joins us tonight I don't know why
this doesn't surprise me this is yet
another guy who flies in private planes
lecturing us about carbon emissions
another guy who's lecturing us about how
we need more women to be empowered who
brutally savaged the woman who came
closest to becoming president like how
much hypocrisy are they capable of a lot
yeah he's also a guy giving a speech in
Denmark whose staff didn't want the
amount he was being paid to be disclosed
or they were gonna threaten to cancel
the species Barack Obama Tucker this is
a very deliberate strategy by the left
listen to me they live in a vacuum of
ignorance they don't have any ideas that
appeal on a popular scale mean what is
their campaign sign going to read you
know give us more of your money dramatic
tax hikes government's just too small we
need more of it they can't run on that
so their deliberate strategy is to fully
engage in identity and identity politics
hence the racism line coming out against
strategically and what it does Tucker is
it gets people to believe that the
Democrats don't vote for us vote against
those guys the Republicans because
they're the real bad guys and we're
gonna be the ones to save you this is a
cynical but very tactical strategy by
the Democrats and it's pretty disgusting
I hate it well I mean now what cost
though because if powerful people get up
and say anyone who opposes your ideas
hates you because of your skin color
people believe that and
didn't make all of us hate each other a
little more um it does Tucker but sadly
this goes back to you know critical
theory which has been taught in school
forever you know the the white
patriarchal power structure I'm that
that bet that power somehow is going to
be necessary for them to acquire back at
any cost to deconstruct this whole thing
that led to where we are now but again
you can only do that by divorcing people
from facts and data and getting them
knee-deep in a quagmire of emotion and
the only way to generate that emotion
that hatred towards your opponents is to
say the most awful things Tuckers or
anything worse you can call someone then
a racist or a bigot the answer is no
that's why they do it all the time it's
the only way to win I can't remember the
last time I heard someone make a
straightforward economic argument on
either side and by the way I'd be
grateful to hear it no matter what the
argument was I just want to hear someone
make a serious argument that doesn't
have to do with motive or intent or your
moral character or racism like tell me
what the economics are no one does yeah
it's it's actually I can't this is too
stupid you're right they can't that's a
great point Dan but Gina I always
learned something thank you